when we think about our biggest enemies
to youtube success
we might be thinking about the external
circumstances
like who's in office or the lockdowns or
just kind of the economical pressures
that are happening right now
or it could be their rising competition
with all of the creators on the platform
we've learned here at think media with
each of our team members creating
content on their own platform
and with us working with thousands of
students and content creators just like
us
that it really comes down to ourselves
holding us back you know it could be the
thought of overcoming negative thinking
or being demotivated when you need to be
making a video
or maybe it could be the toxic habits
holding you back from creating your best
content so
i'm excited for you to hear this episode
and i actually think this is going to be
the most powerful podcast
yet where you're going to learn how to
have your best year yet
and you're going to learn how to get
more views and subscribers and build a
freedom based
business on youtube because you're
getting over the thing
that's holding you back my name is
heather torres and you're listening to
the think
marketing podcast the number one podcast
for helping you grow your influence
on youtube and turn that influence into
a high
impact and high profit online business
and if you're new to the podcast i want
to encourage you to subscribe
wherever you're consuming this content
from we love to
deliver content to you every single
tuesday so make sure you're subscribed
so you never miss an episode
now i want to warn you we didn't
actually know we were going to record
this but we
did what we tell our students to do and
that was to just punch fear in the face
and press record so
on parts of this episode the audio's a
little sketch but
i mean come on we just wanted to put
this together for you
so that you could maybe get a
behind-the-scenes look at how we are
developing leaders and
really what we are doing to have our
best year
ever and stick around to the end of this
episode
where i'm going to be sharing with you
how you can get an all-access
pass to the number one youtube marketing
conference
for content creators and business owners
all of that is happening at the end of
this
episode so let's go ahead and get into
the featured content
today my assigned message
is titled uh how to have the best year
ever
in 2021 and
i think that i believe um god has really
stirred
my heart with a theme for the year
um the official title of today is
is how to have the best year ever in
2021 by having your
best year ever in 2021
how to have the best year ever in 2021
by having your best year ever
in 2021 and i really feel like i have a
theme
for the year and uh
and that is
and then things went then things went
silence then things went sideways man
they were like
and that was
sonia goes did you order an axe on
amazon
and should i be afraid and i said there
was no way if i was gonna use it for
that that i would leave a trail like
that
i'd pay cash at a local hardware store
come on
hey i think that uh that really the
theme
for 2021 is sharpen the axe
[Music]
is sharpen the axe hey
ecclesiastes 10 10 it says this it says
using a dull axe requires great
strength so sharpen the blade that's the
value of wisdom it helps you succeed
and abraham lincoln was credited for
saying but quote
disapproval disproved that he said it
but we're going to pretend he did
because it's still a powerful quote and
it's
give me six hours to chop down a tree
and i will spend the first
four sharpening the axe sharpening
the ax and when i think about
this theme i um i grew up on a farm i
grew up on six acres
in arlington washington uh we had goats
we had multiple different dogs
um they all died quite regularly um
kyle's like hey man yeah hit by cars you
know other dog
dog fights seriously like neighbor dogs
like brawls
hitting dogs with shovels our dog
getting you know things on his neck and
then bleeding out and dying and uh you
know a lot of
it was a it took a this is a dark it's a
dark day
this is produced by blumhouse
productions deep
cut reference right there uh so
so so i grew up on a farm though and and
did a lot of farm things
yeah i may not look look it with his uh
metro
and his um jordan ones as i am right now
but
um i grew up on a farm and i actually
cut a lot of wood because we we had a
wood fire stove
and um we would have to split kindling
split wood my stepdad phil eskelin
taught me how to
how to make kindling and we would use
different splitting malls we'd use
different hatchets
and different axes just like this one
and you definitely learned
that if you have a dull blade it took so
much more
strength to maybe split an entire
uh group of firewood right it was it was
it was four times the energy you're
sweating by the end of it
whereas if you were to sharpen the blade
and have a sharp blade
um and and and skill with how you would
cut i'd watch my dad he'd often times
grab a maul
not from here but he'd grab it right
here and he'd just like pop off kindling
like real quick like this
and uh you'd have these big you know
depends on how dry the wood is and how
easy it is to split
and uh and he would just be able to just
bust through
you know all kinds of firewood but again
if the blade was dull
it took so much more energy it took so
much more strength but if you sharpen
the blade
you were able to get more done in less
time with less stress
more peace of mind and when i think
about this very
powerful verse in the bible that applies
so much to business and life
ecclesiastes 10 10 using adult axe
requires great strength so sharpen the
blade that's the value of wisdom it
helps you succeed
and think media i believe is going to
have
its best year ever this next year and
we've had our best year ever but we're
gonna have our best year ever next year
if you have your best year
ever and uh
it starts with you it starts with me
let's all say it starts with me
yeah it starts with me i i know for a
fact that we are called to lead
thousands i mean we already lead
millions but
but i mean lead uh you know leadership
is influence like really
influence people really change their
lives but the first person we have to
lead
is ourselves is ourselves um michael
jordan said this
talented players win games but teamwork
and intelligence
win championships this afternoon or at
the end of today we'll do our second
session we're going to talk about team
but the first part of that quote we're
going to talk about the players that's
you that's me
talented players win games and there's
something about
sharpening your talent what i love when
you study the greats
like a kobe mayhew rest in power or a
michael jordan or a lebron you see
how much energy they put into their
practices how even after winning the
game they'd be back in the gym the next
day
they realize the power of the team but
they also realize the power of the
player
and the and talented players win games
so we need to grow as players and as
player coaches it starts with you
it starts with me and babe ruth said
this
home yesterday's home runs don't win
today's
games and here's one of our biggest
vulnerabilities friends we had an
epic year in 2020 my god we're gonna
talk about some stats later on but like
i mean just we did things we've never
done before we had challenges we've
we've put up five videos a week
we get like a quarter million views on
our youtube channel every two days
um we are breaking all of our financial
records we we've added to the team
we're having an incredible year and
we've had
so many home runs this year but
yesterday's home runs don't win today's
game so here's just some questions do
you
think you could accomplish more this
next year than you did last year
do you think you could earn more money
this next year than you did last year
well that's up to you sean you control
that well yeah but actually you control
that
i mean if you make yourself so
indispensable so
um so vital if you
if you double a department
and you say this is the campaign i want
to try this is the thing i want to do
this is what i think
i could influence think media's goal is
to have no lid on your financial future
do you think you could earn more money
this next year than you did
last year some of you have side projects
do you think you could earn more money
this next year than you did last year
do you think you can manage your time
better this next year
in 2021 than you did this year
hey how about this do you think it'd be
possible to manage your emotions better
this next year
would it be possible for us as a team to
get more done
with less stress and in less time this
next year
you know i think it would but here's
here's
what i think is one of our biggest
enemies it's the doll axe mentality
because at the end of 2020 you may be
feeling great you may be feeling
fatigued and you may go
uh sean i don't think so i mean 2020 was
great but i hit my max i hit my limit i
hit the lid like so i could do that
again but i hit i mean i hit the lid i
can only split so much
firewood i can only actually produce so
much
but what if we spent more time
sharpening the axe
sharpening the blade so that it took
less strength
to achieve the same results if not more
results that's why i really think the
theme this year is to sharpen the axe
because on an overarching
goal sean what's what are we going to do
in 2021
a lot of the same stuff we did in 2020
almost entirely because 2020
was a pioneering year we didn't have we
didn't have coffee with kennel show now
we do let's refine it
let's dial it in we didn't have the
think marketing live show let's refine
it
we actually didn't have the podcast
let's refine it let's refine our
workflows we've never done a challenge
we're going to try to do a challenge or
quarter this next year
let's refine it it was a stretch to be
doing a video a week and then two videos
a week
and it was like oh my gosh how could we
do that but could we do it with less
stress more margin
and more peace of mind and actually get
more done in less time this next year
by simply sharpening the x the doll axe
mentality tells us
that my results are fixed because i'm
getting what i'm getting and i have
nothing left at the end of the day
you know as a runner uh and one that was
a hobby runner to a semi-hobby runner to
now like an
amateur pro amateur hobbyist runner
um i've been taking this thing kind of
seriously
and and at first i was just kind of
haphazardly running on a treadmill in
irvine california back when we lived
there and
then we moved to to uh vegas and now
we have the loop that is in southern
highlands that i often run most mornings
and you might see me on instagram
stories
i'm on my way to just run the loop
that's about two and a half miles
and i used to not even be able to run
that entire loop and
i would go out and i would kind of jog
for a while i'd get super huffy and
puffy
i'd kind of get sore my heart rate would
be all crazy so i'd have to walk for a
while and then i would jog again and
walk again
years back i remember i ran that loop
with my friend
andy james and i remember he was a
pretty good runner and i was like dude
how
there was this one slightly inclined
part
that it's just slightly i mean i'm not
even that's like just slightly inclined
and he was going up and i was like this
is like
this hill is going to kill me are we
running up everest like what are we
talking about right and
and now over the years i've been
sharpening the axe
and i'll go out and just smash the two
and a half miles i'm not even tired
after
like i got my endurance is at such a
foundation where 19 and a half really
fatigues me and i feel sore
but now it's like it's it's actually in
a way effortless and i'm faster than i
was
and it's now even fun where before it
wasn't even fun
it was stressed out emotionally fried
heart rate crazy to now i'm like that's
that's just
because my endurance level right because
my strength level
and so we can accomplish and sometimes
still
dull acts thinking and fixed thinking is
like well
we're maxed out my my calendar is maxed
out my capacities maxed out
and if we sharpen the ax though we could
accomplish more than ever before so in
this first session
the way we're gonna have the best year
ever in 2021 is by having your best year
ever
and i've got a couple areas and then
three tips and then we're done
and uh and the first one is
it's all about being personal this first
session is about us personally as
leaders so
we want to sharpen the acts by leveling
up personally as leaders and here's a
couple areas that i think
you could consider and i could consider
how could i sharpen the axe in these
areas
in 2021 and it's going to affect
everything
it's going to affect everything the
first one is energy i think about that
as like
as like our bodies you know if we want
to get i learned that if i wanted to get
different results
to be able to run with more endurance my
sleep mattered
my hydration mattered the food i was
eating mattered that was the endurance
piece
i do know that for those content
creators you all get it y'all are doing
crazy batches we're batch and think
marketing podcasts and different things
and
people who watch think media go batching
seems impossible
i don't know if i could have the mental
clarity i don't know if i could have the
physical energy to do it and you go well
that wasn't built overnight we've been
sharpening the
axe for years so is it possible to
do a live stream and do this and and
here's our goal this next year
right is to is to get to the end of grow
with video live
and actually not feel like we got hit by
a bus we're about to
grab an axe and murder our family like
the shining and
and come on and just absolutely be fried
but to get to the end and be
tired know that you just worked out but
be able to even recover faster
and have it that's an energy thing
question is like
how can i have more energy how can i
have more endurance that's the body
the next area is the mindset that's the
brain if energy is the body mindset's
the brain
how can i how can i be more sharper
mentally
how can i have more mental toughness and
i would challenge you that in our
industry especially
in a discontinuous change in what we're
facing
mental toughness is the game being able
to hold it together
up here being able to as more of you and
many of you are on camera
or or in high pressure situations
where you're you're going and and and i
think about
just how dynamic heather has been at
different times this year
and one time when she did a live stream
but she got a phone call right before
that could not only did it kind of knock
her off her game
but she wouldn't have known it nobody
would have known it why is a mental
toughness thing
literally a call that would have
sidelined a lot of people and of course
there's those times when maybe you get a
call where you're sidelined
and uh and that's okay because you know
if you got if you got to take a break if
you got you got to know self-awareness
if you need to sit this one out
but mental toughness is you got live
stream chat thrown at you with negative
comments and haters
you've got drama happening in your
family that's been happening all morning
long and you're supposed to do a live
stream
and now you're in a pressure situation
where sean is calling you out on zoom in
the morning and asking you for some
numbers and you feel the pressure
like it's pressure like there's times
when we feel pressure that's
mental toughness that's that mindset so
different areas we could sharpen
in 2021 how are you working on your
energy and your endurance two
how are you working on your mindset your
brain if your energy is your body
how you working on your attitude number
three attitude and emotions that's your
heart
if energy is your body if mindsets your
brain attitude emotions is the heart
emotional management
we call this emotional mastery now
we have all kinds of different diverse
enneagram numbers in this room and i'm
so excited to learn about how you
process your emotions
i don't process mine but uh but but
here's actually
what i've learned as a uh
as a uh as as as as leaders
it actually is important that we grow to
higher levels of emotional mastery no
matter what
our enneagram number is because the
truth is emotions are indicators they're
not dictators
emotions are indicators that like a gas
light in your car or like an oil light
like you probably need to change the oil
but if you're driving down the street
and the oil light turns on you don't go
oh my gosh
turn over start a live stream on
instagram and you'd be like i can't
believe it
i'm gonna need to do an oil change mom i
think i need to change the oil
something's wrong i'm losing it no you
scor
you schedule an oil change and you
address it because there is something
that's happening
with emotions but how you react they're
indicators they're not dictators
emotional immaturity and leadership
immaturity is letting emotions
dictate your facial expressions
your energy how you show up that day
emotional mastery is like yeah i'm going
through some stuff but i know that
people are counting on me
i know that my attitude can lift or
reduce the room i know that my energy
even on zoom
can actually affect things so it's the
attitude and emotional mastery just how
are we working on our hearts and i think
about
over the years for me whether it's been
spiritual practice
whether it's been counseling whether
it's been reading i've wanted to get
stronger
in my heart because the inner game is
the game the mental toughness is the
game and the inner game is the game
a couple others communication these are
just like how can we sharpen the acts
communication what do i mean
self-talk how you're talking to yourself
how you bounce back from
negative comments on a video in my
presentation
of my enneagram uh it's one of these
things that shows that this is how i
think of myself this big inflated
balloon of ego
and one little negative uh a comment is
like a pin
that can deflate that instantly and i'll
think about it all day long
and so but but i've had to work on my
self-taught game how about this
team talk like we are not
in isolation uh we need each other now
and we'll talk about that later but when
we need a tether
it's how we're it's how we're talking to
the team it's do we talk
i want to grow and making sure i'm
talking in a respectful and a loving and
maybe a challenging but knowing
i'm going to learn your personalities
friendship and family talk
you know communication i think about
that because
this personal aspect you we're going
gonna win
championships because of talented
players working together
if we're leveling up as players together
i found that one of the biggest things
that can disrupt
think media is drama in my family
can i be honest sometimes
it's really hard to live with sonia i'm
just kidding
it's the opposite it's the opposite
sometimes
for sonia to live with sean and
sometimes listen communication
sometimes i don't communicate very good
and sometimes that could just be
communicating ahead with my spouse that
i'm going to be going live
or that something's coming up or that
something's happening
turns out when i don't communicate that
it starts a domino effect
so now we're starting the morning
there's a lot at stake that day it's a
challenge that day it sees some stuff to
put out there's some live streams that
day there's some important team meetings
that day
well now we're fighting that meeting
starting at nine
we're fighting at 8 53
this is affecting my emotions this is
affecting her emotions this
is i'm now no longer in my peak state
to be the best player
for the game that's ahead that can
happen with friends it can happen with
family so if we're going to sharpen the
x it actually just has to do with our
interpersonal relationships and
realizing
um your personal life is your personal
life but your life at think is also
an at-will employer that we get to
decide how you're showing up so there's
something about
managing your communication and then
relationships drama and toxic
relationships can not
knock you off track for minutes days or
weeks and that's up to you but i just
think about sharpening the x man we're
on a mission we got impact to do
you sometimes have to ask yourself you
know are
these can i even handle consuming this
toxicity
when there's thousands even millions
depending on us for leadership
for encouragement for motivation so you
can write this down
what's your weakest area personally
and what and what if strengthened which
area if strengthened would create a
domino effect in every
other area of your life and it could be
one of those areas it might just be
something that you go you know what
man that's a vulnerability that's the
thing that knocks me off track i mean
maybe it is
maybe as your energy your body maybe
it's your mindset your brain and working
on self-talk and
maybe it's heart and emotions and man
sometimes emotions get you know
maybe it's communication and it's it's
your own self-talk or it's it's
relationship with others in the team or
relationships with family
and and and that that's that's one that
probably
ever since we've been married for 15
years now and ever since we were interns
together at a church and every single
wednesday
we would serve together we would start
the morning praying at like seven
and by seven at night we were having
youth group and we would do
outreach all day and make videos all day
and do all the stuff and
every day like clockwork we were
fighting in sonia's honda civic by 4
30 because of
pressure and because of learning
communication and whatnot and i was like
i need to minister to youth tonight
why are you and and she's like yeah but
you don't even love me
you know and we're like 20. and so
you know but uh but but just what area
what area for you
what's your weakest area personally that
if strengthened
listen would create an abdominal effect
in every area of your life
and hear me in every area of your life i
know we're talking about personal stuff
here
and i do i want us to make an impact and
think media but i care about you
personally
i that this stuff will make you happier
it'll lift the relationships around you
my hope is this that if you're connected
to think media your whole life
flourishes and prospers
never happens instantly because seeds
take time to grow
but that when we sharpen the acts this
year i want to see
vibrancy in every area your joy your
relationship with families
it's not a problem free life but it
really is a blessed
life because
we are seeing the impact of walking in
wisdom
so what area is your write that down i
may be thinking that could be maybe a
2021
sharpen the axe area for you as we land
the plane
with six minutes and 51 seconds i'm
feeling good
right as we sharpen
the axe this year here are just three
quick
personal sharpening the act strategies
that i think that we could implement
this next year
that could help us these have helped me
and these are ones i'm working on
number one is a prize fighter morning
routine
it is a prize fighter morning routine if
we have a better
2021 in every area of our life but
especially
on the days we're working right
especially on the days
where the main thing we're doing that
day is think media
man a prize fighter morning routine can
change everything couple thoughts
um you know for me this this was
impacted when i was a campus pastor of a
church and we were
in arguably one of the second hardest
seasons of our life
the amount of pressure new season
potential
leadership dysfunction that we're
dealing with we're also young leaders
and so we're trying to navigate that
and i found myself during this time i'm
drinking more than i should
i'm trying to process my emotions more
than i should
uh in negative ways um and i'm making i
have a lot of bad habits
because some nights i'm maybe staying up
too late
and i find myself getting up every
morning trying to climb like a mountain
that's insurmountable of what felt like
emotions or
the enemies that were in front of me and
i actually discovered a book called
the miracle morning and it helped me
regain
control of my mornings and the author
how elrod talked about how he was
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
debt in his business basically he felt
like he was drowning and i felt like i
was drowning in the season
and he's and he's thought he said i mean
i have to actually win the morning even
if the day basically kicks my butt i
need to win the morning
and i need to win the morning even
before 8 a.m that i got to get up get my
mind right get my heart right get my
spirit right
and i'm sure we can all relate you've
probably all had a great morning routine
and then
like me you still get up sometimes like
kind of like a little bit late and you
don't do much
and you're kind of like you know a
little bit tired a little bit fatigued
and you sort of stumble
into whatever your responsibility is
that day as opposed to dominate that
first moment of your day
this is really the rise and grind spirit
is it not
and so just a couple thoughts i learned
that a great morning starts the night
before
that really it's impossible to have a
world-class morning without a
world-class
evening and then and this book simply
teaches savers
it's uh this is an acronym for just some
things that you could include in your
morning routine
that you might try and that's a book and
by the way because i think media right
we'll hook you up with any book you want
physically or ebook or
audiobook miracle morning if you want to
check it out but it teaches
what he did was he studied all the
world-class achievers
in different industries could be like
religion business
athletics and he found that they had
different things that they did in their
morning routines
he then combined them all into one hour
where you would do these things in an
hour and then it was like an accordion
where you could do these things in 30
minutes and you could even do them in
two minutes
and so it's silence affirmations
visualization exercise
uh reading and scripting which is a
fancy word for writing
savers write it down s-a-v-o-r-s
savers silence affirmations
visualization exercise
reading and scripting savers
so even if you did in two minutes you
get up you take some silence you take
some silent time before no phone
know anything and you're silent maybe a
time where you just think about
gratitude for me i'm like thanking god
for life
silence a few moments of silence before
the day gets crazy
affirmations used to think they were
cheesy learn they weren't
learned that when i wake up in the
morning
my mind usually drifts kind of towards
negativity and overwhelm
so written affirmations whatever that
means it could be a prayer it could be
declarations there's a lot of things you
could refine there
it it is choosing to be intentional over
your emotions and your mind as opposed
to just letting your mind run wild and
be like
frick got a lot to do man i wonder if
that's
if uh if she's still thinking that about
me i think she is thinking that about me
gosh i wonder if sean's mad i think he
probably is man i wonder
i wonder if me and my husband are gonna
be i wonder you know
like you get it so so affirmations the
third is visualization this is powerful
world-class athletes um close their eyes
and visualize the game they're about to
play they think about being in the
locker room they think about putting
their shoes on they think about playing
the game they think about the shots
they're gonna make they think about how
the crowd is going to sound they think
about the haters that are going to be
waving you know things to distract them
and how they're going to shut that out
world class snowboarders think about the
whole course they've practiced and they
think about how they're going to
do that 720 court rodeo flip they think
about how they're going to land how it's
going to feel
they actually play out the game in their
mind content creators if you're going to
go live
or you're going to speak on stage and
any kind of thing like that that's
that's a major thing of actually playing
out
how am i going to close how am i going
to open how are people going to feel
what's what's going to be that's
visualization
e is uh for exercise savers i give you
the wrong letter it's savers not ors or
whatever there's no o
so silence affirmations visualization
exercise this doesn't mean
two hours of weight lifting it means
maybe you just stretch and go for a walk
i found if you go outside get some fresh
air changes everything you know
uh and then uh re reading
which is scripting the last s or no
reading as they are and and that's just
like reading something
i read like my bible for my spiritual
practice but i like to just read
something that's going to get my mind
sharpened
get my you know get me in the mode of of
kind of business
usually more kind of like kind of like a
think and grow rich book or kind of like
a limitless book by jim quick something
like that it just kind of gets me
thinking bigger
and then finally scripting is writing is
journaling a little bit and this might
be where like what are my priorities
today
what am i who are the people i need to
reach out today all that kind of stuff
but the scripting as i destroy my time
now that i
brag too early but i will land the plane
quick uh
scripting is and writing um could also
be writing out your intention for the
day
what if we set an intention like this is
how i want people to feel on zoom today
i wanna i want the team to feel
encouraged or today you know this is
what the intention of the day is okay so
just a prize fighting morning routine
i don't think there's anything about
trying to copy somebody else's morning
routine but i would argue this
it's impossible to be world class
without a world-class morning routine
that you design yourself
and so if we sharpen the acts in 2021
it's by winning our morning so we can
win the day
second pdp
what is your personal development plan
for 2021 we could talk about that later
and just for speed but uh the question
is like what did you want to grow in
this
next year some years i wanted to grow as
a leader every year
some years i've wanted to be get better
at delegating though some years
i want to be better at thinking about
how to manage our finances as a family
some years
i want to think about growing in
different areas
of communication or speaking it's kind
of like what are you studying
and when you have a personal development
plan it means your personal development
and growth is intentional
not haphazard and number three
heather's favorite planning
planning time blocking so
um
so our personal axe sharpening
strategies a prize fighting morning
routine we win the morning we'll win the
day
we have a personal development plan
we're sharpening the axe all year long
but planning is about order in your life
right about order in your life all the
parents say yes and amen
they realize that as soon as you shift
in that season you need a whole other
dimension of planning
just to survive like you might not even
be thriving you're just trying to get
through the day with planning
but something about ordering your life
if we want to have order and think media
we need order in our personal lives like
because we all
are interconnected right talented
players win games but teams win
championships but as talented players
is taking it to another level of
planning write this down
this is one thing i'd love for us to do
in 2021 is seeing further in the future
and just thinking further ahead and
having more foresight
so constantly just thinking more into
the future oh man okay so if i do this
ten part
video series well that could go here and
i could think even further ahead
that could get us even further ahead we
could even record sean's leadership
talks here
that could get us two podcasts and we
could put those out with now those are
done so that gets us even further ahead
and we only have 52 podcasts this year
so how could we do well actually if we
cut these into two parts that's
four leadership podcasts because we
could do and so
just more foresight but more planning
and i love this quote from brian tracy
every minute you spend planning saves
you 10 minutes in execution
and gives you a 1 000 return on energy
my friends that's a sharpening the act
strategy
because if you go dollax end of the day
i'm freaking exhausted man and all the
wood's not even chopped yet
but if you go man every minute spent in
planning saves 10 minutes in execution
and gives you a 1 000 return on energy
my friends we can do
we can do what we did in 2020 better in
2021 and my goal
is that we'd have more fun doing it is
that we would have more margin doing it
is that we're gonna have times of
pressure and stress that's normal and
healthy
but we're gonna have less we're not
gonna hit verges of burnout
mel after grow with video
the call out was real at the end of
growth video live
map's probably my fault but it's also
your
personal management fault right so
so listen planning thinking further
ahead
delegation
the delivery of love i told you earlier
i already confessed communication team
talks
no you're world class you're amazing
it's out of heart for you i don't want
you to be
on the verge
okay the plane is being landed with some
quotes
final plane landing quotes zig ziglar
said this
people often say that motivation doesn't
last well neither does bathing that's
why we recommend it daily
pdp man price fighting morning routine
we keep we keep it hot we keep it sharp
all year long
what you do daily determines what you
become permanently john c
maxwell you will never change your life
until you change something you do
daily the secret to your success is
found in your daily routine
and so my friends 2021 it's time to
sharpen the axe
and it starts with me and it starts
with you that this year we're going to
do a lot of the same things but we're
going to do them better we're going to
do them smarter
let's sharpen the axe that's the value
of wisdom
it helps us succeed
well i hope that that brought you value
i hope getting that
fly on the wall behind the scenes
experience with what we do here at think
media was helpful to you and your
content journey
and i want to just walk through those
questions again that sean asked and that
first question was do you think you can
accomplish more this year than last year
i want you to get a journal out and
actually write these down because
this is what's going to move you forward
in your youtube career the next question
was
do you think you can earn more money
this year than last year and i
personally i believe that you can if you
start treating
youtube like a business if you start to
see the potential and you commit to the
sacrifice
of creating the content also do you
think you can
manage your time better in 2021 if you
know anything about us here at think
media this is one of the
biggest pieces that we love to tell you
about
and that's time management can you get
your google calendar right can you
know when you're wanting to make those
videos and edit those videos
do you know when you want to be on
social media owning your time
is so important what about would it be
possible to
manage your emotions better in 2021 i
know for me this is a big one
i get triggered when i'm on social media
and when i'm
talking with friends about the things
that are happening in this world i have
a deep heart for
wanting change to happen but the emotion
can be overtaking and sometimes
that can make me unmotivated to want to
create content
or be on the platform to be able to be
talking to people so
can you manage your emotions better so
that you can get more done
and then the last one is it possible to
get more done
with less stress in less time i think
that if we are striving for that that's
how we build those freedom-based
businesses
i don't want you to be chained to your
business i want you to be
in a fruitful business that gives you
the time and the energy
and all of the things that are possible
for you on youtube
so i hope this encouraged you and
today's episode was actually brought to
you by
grow with video live the number one
youtube
marketing conference for entrepreneurs
and business-minded
content creators and i'm excited because
you could win
one of three free all-access
passes to our upcoming fall 2021
grow with video live event this is a
virtual event so no matter where you
live in the world you can win
a ticket and come to this conference now
there's a couple details that you'll
need to do and that's
number one rating and reviewing the
podcast
it's very simple you can do it on itunes
rate and review the podcast and then go
to
thinkmarketingshow.com and that's where
you have all of the details i'll make
sure that's linked down in the
description below
so you can go there rate and review the
podcast and enter to win
one of these all access passes again
details
are at thinkmarketingshow.com and i want
to read
one of the reviews from someone who's
entered into this giveaway this is d
witters and he said this wisdom is so
fire with a fire emoji
needed to hear this 100 thank you hey
dee thank you so much for rating and
reviewing the podcast you are entered in
to win one of those
all-access passes to growth video live
happening in fall
of 2021 thank you so much for listening
to today's podcast and i'm excited for
the next episode where we're going to be
diving into
the marketing trends of 2021 that you
need to know about thanks so much for
being here and we'll catch it in the
next episode
[Music]
you